-This is a true story.
Well, not -- it's inspired by
a true story.
I don't know if these guys were
actually --
-Word for word.
-Word for word?
-This is actually a documentary.
-This is a documentary.
But these are friends,
a group of friends
who have been playing
a real game of Tag for 30 years.
-Yeah, it's true.
There was a "Wall Street
Journal" profile on these guys.
They're from
Spokane, Washington.
[ Audience cheers ]
There is 10 of them.
We scaled it down
for narrative reasons to five.
-Yeah. And it's cash, right?
-Right, right.
We couldn't afford it.
-Yeah, right. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-But they really do play
this game.
And it's actually kind of
a beautiful thing
because it's kept them together
as friends for 30 years.
You know, when you get older --
-Yeah.
-...it's harder to stay in touch
with people.
We have Facebook and stuff now.
But to actually be
in the same place,
this game does that for them
and it's a beautiful thing.
-It is a beautiful thing.
I still think it would be
a hard sell if I told my wife
I got to -- it's Tag time.
[ Laughter ]
No matter how many years I've
been doing it, I think --
-"Sorry, honey,
you got the kids tonight.
I got to go run around and tag."
-"I got my tag thing."
-Yeah.
Well, it is only one month
out of the year.
-Well that's -- I guess she --
She would definitely
give me that, yeah.
-So it's reasonable. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Jeremy Renner is one of
your cast mates.
And one of your other cast
mates, Annabelle Wallis was here
talking about how he broke
both his arms.
-Right.
-She was not one of the taggers.
You are.
-Yeah.
-Did you get hurt?
Any injuries for you?
-No, I didn't.
I didn't get hurt at all.
And it's worth, I think,
pointing out that Jason Bourne
and the guy
from "Mission: Impossible"
and Hawkeye the Avenger
got hurt.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And I did not.
-You came out -- yeah.
-I came out unscathed.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, do you think -- do you
think the industry has noticed?
-Well, that's what's so weird is
that now there is all this buzz.
'Cause everyone was like,
"Helms got out scot-free,
without a scratch, so like maybe
he's the next big action star."
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
And it's like --
I'm just hearing all this buzz.
I don't know where it started.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
-But this is a palpable buzz
in Hollywood?
-Palpable buzz, Seth.
-Wow.
-Seth, it's -- I mean, this
is -- it's buzzing.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Everyone is like,
"He's gonna be --"
And this is -- I mean,
I'm very humbled by this.
There's Oscar buzz.
-There's Oscar buzz too?
-Yeah, for me.
Yeah, and I, again, I don't know
where it started.
I don't know.
-Wow.
Is it the Oscar for not getting
hurt on the set?
[ Laughter ]
-It's because I just --
I transformed in this role.
-All right.
So here's my question though.
So Renner's Hawkeye.
If Ed Helms is now the new
action star, superhero guy,
what would be a good superhero
for you?
-So I've been thinking
about that.
When I do get the call from
Marvel, what am I gonna say?
[ Laughter ]
And I think a good one would be,
because Renner's Hawkeye,
I could be Hawkguy.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
-Seems very similar.
-No. It's not. It's not at all.
Because Renner runs around with
a bow and arrow.
And I'm just the guy who knows
a lot about hawks.
-Oh, okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Hawkguy, he's like your go-to
guy for hawk-related trivia.
-Gotcha. Facts.
-A lot of people
don't know this.
Falcons and hawks
get confused a lot.
-Gotcha.
-Right?
But Hawkguy can tell you
the difference.
-Gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
Could he tell me
a lot about falcons
or would he push me off
to someone else for that?
-Yeah, he'd push you off
to Falconguy.
-Right, exactly.
-Obviously.
[ Laughter ]
-Not to be confused with
the falcon.
-Jon Hamm is gonna be Falconguy.
-Yeah.
-And I'll be Hawkguy.
-That's great.
I think your scenes
will be the best in that film.
-It's just like I said -- don't
know where the buzz started.
[ Laughter ]
So humbled by it.
-So humbled by the buzz.
-But we'll see what happens.
-You shot in Atlanta,
which is where you are from.
-My hometown, yeah.
Atlanta, Georgia.
-So how was that?
Was it nice to be back home?
-It's awesome.
I do -- I love going back home.
It, you know, stirs up
a lot of old memories,
old jobs and school and stuff.
-Where were -- What was young
Ed Helms doing for jobs?
-Well, I worked --
I was a lifeguard.
-All right.
-At a pool.
-Oh, that's where they do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's funny.
When you say
that you were a lifeguard,
people are like,
"Whoa, that's impressive."
I was not impressive.
-Okay.
-I was a lifeguard
at a city pool.
The most I did, like, the most
heroic thing I did
was stopped children from peeing
in the pool.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And that's --
-If you are stopping them from
peeing in the pool,
that means they're doing it
from outside the pool?
'Cause otherwise how --
[ Laughter ]
How can you tell?
-No, you can tell.
-You can?
-You can absolutely tell.
Because they can be
in the middle of, like,
a crazy game of Marco Polo,
and when they start to pee,
they just drift away.
[ Laughter ]
And they get this blank look
on their face.
And it's just -- they're like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It strikes me that
once you see that face,
it's already too late.
-It's too late.
But you can shame them into
hopefully not doing it again.
-I see. I gotcha.
-Right?
-So you're policing
the next time out?
-I'm a child shamer.
[ Laughter ]
-That's really what a lifeguard
was, a child shamer.
-Let's go back to Oscar buzz.
[ Laughter ]
Because again,
somebody keeps saying it.
Somebody keeps repeating it.
-Yeah, no, I've heard it a lot
in the last five minutes.